welcome to this video playing Dark virus
dark virus from Russia we have a an
English opening I went for an e5 setup
which I don't do so often it's um exam
now the type of formation that is
usually known as what vinick's set up
with c4 ID for many possible ways to
play h5 is one of them trying to
irritate white or is not reacting to it
at all this is a bit a bit uncommon
normally white is some playing on
something like um 830 h4 interesting
okay I can also go here why not deform
it cannot go age three yeah I think this
should be quite ok 44 black shouldn't
that time in can even consider Bishop g7
yeah maybe get rid of this somewhat
somewhat bad Bishop here yeah okay
should I take or not yeah probably so
probably I should
the question is what about how to how to
play that if I go here yeah maybe make
sure that and the bishop has some role
just exchange it for a good night and
I'll now see what he's doing he plays
Queen takes at Queen g5 ok and here
let's see how to how to play that defile
maybe defaults coming
hmm yeah if you move through the night I
have night before that that is a good
thing to have I'm not sure where I put
this this night on his own reading this
night on Jade to e 79 probably I mean
Knight f6 is not so attractive maybe
night h6 with the idea to play Knight g4
and with this to prepare fi if this
could be an idea what happens if i take
it no okay
hmm i don't really think that this is so
but this is enough for wide i have a
very close very close sentinel now let's
it's interesting
might be five mmm interesting
okay well I just I just drive it back
and then see what happens if it goes 95
I have night see to it seven I must I
really must get rid of this this piece
itself public enemy number one okay
oh I played a plate for to Sloan him 113
I died really didn't pay attention at
the two o'clock
yeah I probably should take the draw
here but I'm not here to play draws him
at 95 might be five I was trying to same
yeah I should have taken the draw but
yeah let's try to to fight here in those
games on video but sometimes not really
great at the end I should take the draw
once in a while okay can take on d6 with
both pieces threatening night g8 now
probably but he can just retreat him
and at least he's taking some time not
sure what I should do against this move
to be honest night I can do night g8 and
so how do I ever get some activity in
this position I duck lettuce Queenie
five maybe
trying trying to set up appt in covering
E 5 and intending 98 maybe he's got all
night 80 Scott Walker takes 36 okay but
he still he needs to find this ok I can
take care ok I can take because I've
chance covered ok I decide didn't
calculate it looks it looks very very
dangerous yeah you five I only have
exact time check that dude I don't have
any extra material I thought I was yours
Ted taken taken now
check time warning check check check
check check check check check check
white forfeits on time whoo-hoo Wow no
idea what was going on there I ok I was
lost of course but but yeah ok well I
should I should just take this this is
draw here and and be content with that
yeah a bit strange all of that before I
don't really believe that I mean cannot
i don't think that this is really a
correct sacrifice but maybe maybe it is
her in the be found that's not yeah i'm
not so well coordinated but he still has
this pad bishop on g2 i don't know i
mean it was it was very tricky that this
is clear probably long castle here yeah
they are the problem is the F porna it
is a constant weakness and to to get rid
of that you you need to play a five but
of course look at the long diagonal I
can never go f5 I can only play a five
if I get the Queen's exchanged then then
it's okay maybe but in this situation
there also was g4 intending oops g5 also
Wow yeah it was a real mess and then
here I try to do to play for win but
this is a probably insane check this was
strong this was strong I guess yeah yeah
I didn't I didn't see that Jack the
ruckus is going away besides the fact
that there are moves like that I mean
what do I play against that one yeah
nothing I guess that's it okay took yeah
it's the low win for white g5 is plus 11
okay yeah it's it's a wind what whatever
way you want it I for some reason he
there wasn't there wasn't a mate I don't
know and he was just hanging on in this
lost position and at the end it was a
time scramble alright thanks for
watching